What do I think of Paul Joseph Watson
supposition that populism is the new
punk slash counterculture?
That's a good question.
I mean you see that you see,
I would say some indication of that on
Youtube,
although it's not easy to get an
unbiased sample of what's going on on
Youtube because of course youtube tends
to present you with things that are akin
to the things that you're already
watching.
It does appear to me that the
conservative commentators on youtube are
playing somewhat of the same role that
the counterculture played.
Let's call it more traditionally,
even though that's a funny thing to say
about the counterculture.
What I'm wondering more is whether or
not not so much whether it's a
counterculture,
but if it's something that's more
specifically associated with a place
that men,
young men are finding their new
political voice online.
Part of the reason that I'm wondering
about that,
although there are a number of female
conservative commentators who also
become popular online,
is because many of the commentators
appear to be man and many of the people
who are following them also appear to be
mad.
And so,
and it's not obvious to me that men,
it's easy now for men,
especially young men,
to have a political voice on campus,
for example,
or perhaps even in public.
Um,
and so maybe they're turning to youtube
to,
to find these viewpoints that aren't
being destroyed,
disseminated widely in the,
in the popular media.